Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Today's episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. Shortly after 3 on the afternoon of Friday December 30 1921, Melbourne cab driver Joseph Graham was strolling up Little Collins Street on his way to the grocery store. All of a sudden, a piercing high-pitched scream rang out. The area was notoriously rowdy, but in the hundreds of times that Joseph had been there,
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本集节目的说明。今天的节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。1921年12月30日星期五下午3点刚过，墨尔本出租车司机约瑟夫·格雷厄姆（Joseph Graham）正沿着小柯林斯街（Little Collins Street）散步，准备去杂货店。突然，一声尖锐刺耳的尖叫声响起。该地区向来以吵闹著称，但在约瑟夫去过那里的几百次中，
he'd never heard such a heart-rending scream. He described it as sounding like, a little girl terrified at what was occurring or what was about to occur. Joseph estimated that the girl was between the ages of 10 and 15. It sounded as if she was being dragged somewhere close by. Five or six more screams followed, each more terrifying than the last, as the girl was slowly drained of energy. Further down the street, another man also heard the screams. He and Joseph glanced around trying to identify where exactly
他从未听过如此撕心裂肺的尖叫声。他形容那听起来像是一个小女孩对正在发生或即将发生的事情感到恐惧。约瑟夫估计那个女孩的年龄在10到15岁之间。听起来她似乎正被拖向附近某个地方。随后又传来了五六声尖叫，每一声都比前一声更令人恐惧，仿佛那个女孩的力气正在一点点耗尽。在街道更远的地方，另一名男子也听到了尖叫声。他和约瑟夫环顾四周，试图确定声音究竟
the noise was coming from. While they couldn't narrow down an exact spot, they seemed to be coming from the direction of Gun Alley. When Joseph Graham heard about Alma Tursky's murder a little over a week later, he went straight to the police to report the screams he'd heard on Little Collins Street on the afternoon of December 30. The officers didn't seem interested. Plenty of people brought their children into the city and it wasn't unusual to hear them screeching for a litany of innocent reasons. Some local business owners brought their
是从哪里传来的。虽然他们无法确定确切地点，但声音似乎来自枪巷（Gun Alley）方向。当约瑟夫·格雷厄姆在一周多后听说阿尔玛·特斯基（Alma Tursky）被谋杀的消息时，他直接去警察局报告了他在12月30日下午在小柯林斯街听到的尖叫声。警官们似乎并不感兴趣。许多人带着孩子进城，听到他们因为各种无辜的原因尖叫并不罕见。一些当地店主带着
children to work with them, including a nearby barber, whose young daughter was known for her screeching. Despite these explanations, Joseph remained certain that what he'd heard wasn't just a child playfully acting up. Meanwhile, at a police station in the regional town of Ballarat, the other man who heard the screams also came forward. Like Joseph, he reported that the screaming occurred sometime between around 3.05 and 3.25pm. But unlike Joseph, he didn't think there were multiple screams, just a single scream that echoed down the street. He thought it was emanating from a derelict lodging house next to Gunn Alley, but as he walked towards the distressing sound, it suddenly stopped. The man convinced himself it was just an unruly child being disciplined by an exasperated parent and carried on with his day. When he heard about Alma Tursky's
孩子一起工作，包括附近的一位理发师，他的小女儿就以尖叫闻名。尽管有这些解释，约瑟夫仍然确信他听到的不仅仅是一个孩子在调皮捣蛋。与此同时，在巴拉瑞特（Ballarat）地区城镇的一个警察局里，另一名听到尖叫声的男子也站了出来。和约瑟夫一样，他报告说尖叫声发生在下午3点05分到3点25分之间。但与约瑟夫不同的是，他认为并没有多次尖叫，只有一声尖叫在街上回荡。他认为声音来自枪巷旁边一栋废弃的寄宿公寓，但当他走向那令人不安的声音时，声音突然停止了。那名男子说服自己，这只是一个被愤怒的父母管教的顽皮孩子，于是继续忙他自己的事。当他听说阿尔玛·特斯基（Alma Tursky）
murder, he thought about contacting the police, but he was unwell at the time and didn't want the publicity. He also assumed the other witness, Joseph Graham, would report it, thus negating his need to do so. When the days passed with no reports about the screams in the papers, he finally decided to come forward, saying there was a stallholder in the Eastern market who could corroborate his version of events. Ballarat police forwarded this information to the detectives fronting the Tershki case. They now had two independent accounts of a girl screaming in fright around Little Collins Street between 3 and 3.30pm on Friday December 30. These reports aligned with the last confirmed sighting of Alma Tursky after she left the Eastern Arcade on the very corner
被谋杀的消息时，他想过联系警察，但他当时身体不适，不想抛头露面。他还以为另一位目击者约瑟夫·格雷厄姆会去报告，因此觉得没必要自己去。几天过去了，报纸上没有任何关于尖叫声的报道，他最终决定站出来，说东市场（Eastern Market）有一位摊主可以证实他的说法。巴拉瑞特警方将此信息转发给了负责特斯基案的侦探。他们现在有了两份独立的证词，都称在12月30日星期五下午3点到3点30分之间，在小柯林斯街附近听到一个女孩惊恐的尖叫声。这些报告与阿尔玛·特斯基在离开东拱廊（Eastern Arcade）后的最后一次确切目击记录相吻合，而东拱廊就在
where the lodging house was located. This posed a major problem for investigators. They'd been working on the theory that Alma had been lured somewhere private to be assaulted before her body was dumped in Gun Alley later that night. What's more, if the screams heard had indeed come from Alma, it vindicated their prime suspect, Colin Ross. vindicated their prime suspect, Colin Ross. When Colin Ross was found guilty of the 12-year-old's murder, his family were left stunned. From the outset of the investigation, they knew there was no way he could have done it. For starters, Colin's brother Stanley Ross worked alongside Collin at the Australian wine saloon. At around 2pm on Friday December 30 1921, Stanley was in his usual spot behind the bar when Collin arrived for work. It was a relatively quiet afternoon. The brothers spent the entire afternoon serving
那栋寄宿公寓所在的街角。这对调查人员来说是一个重大问题。他们一直基于这样一种理论进行调查：阿尔玛被诱骗到某个私密地方遭到袭击，然后她的尸体在当晚晚些时候被丢弃在枪巷。更重要的是，如果听到的尖叫声确实来自阿尔玛，那就证明了他们的主要嫌疑人科林·罗斯（Colin Ross）是无辜的。当科林·罗斯被判谋杀这名12岁女孩罪名成立时，他的家人感到震惊。从调查一开始，他们就知道他绝不可能做出这种事。首先，科林的兄弟斯坦利·罗斯（Stanley Ross）在澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙（Australian Wine Saloon）与科林一起工作。1921年12月30日星期五下午2点左右，斯坦利像往常一样站在吧台后面，这时科林来上班了。那是一个相对安静的下午。兄弟俩整个下午都在为
and interacting with the few clientele. At no point did Stanley see a young girl matching Alma Turski's description in the saloon. Collins sometimes brought women into the private room behind the bar, but they were never as young as Alma. Former bartender Ivy Matthews and saloon customer Frances Upton had both served as star witnesses for the prosecution, implicating Colin in the young girl's murder. Both claimed they had been drinking at the Australian Wine Saloon Friday December 30, 1921, where they ordered drinks at the bar. But Stanley had been behind the bar all afternoon, and at no point did he see either one of them.
少数顾客服务并与他们互动。斯坦利在沙龙里从未见过任何符合阿尔玛·特斯基特征的年轻女孩。科林有时会带女人进入吧台后面的私人房间，但她们从来没有像阿尔玛那么年轻。前调酒师艾薇·马修斯（Ivy Matthews）和沙龙顾客弗朗西斯·厄普顿（Frances Upton）都曾作为控方的主要证人，指控科林谋杀了这个年轻女孩。两人都声称她们在1921年12月30日星期五在澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙喝酒，并在吧台点了酒。但斯坦利整个下午都站在吧台后面，他从未见过她们中的任何一个。
The only witness he did see was Olive Maddix. Olive had testified to seeing an underage girl matching Alma's description drinking in the parlour and had confronted Colin about it. Yet, according to Stanley, this never happened. Olive did briefly greet Colin at the bar, but the pair didn't engage in any meaningful conversation, and she never mentioned the presence of a young girl. Stanley and Colin remained at the saloon together until closing time, at which point Colin went home for dinner while Stanley ate at a nearby restaurant. At 7.30pm Stanley returned to the saloon to use the bathroom.
他唯一见到的证人是奥利夫·马迪克斯（Olive Maddix）。奥利夫曾作证说看到一个符合阿尔玛特征的未成年女孩在客厅喝酒，并就此事质问过科林。然而，据斯坦利说，这从未发生过。奥利夫确实在吧台简短地向科林打了招呼，但两人并没有进行任何有意义的交谈，她也从未提到过有一个年轻女孩在场。斯坦利和科林一直待在沙龙里直到打烊，随后科林回家吃晚饭，而斯坦利在附近的一家餐馆吃饭。晚上7点30分，斯坦利回到沙龙使用洗手间。
No one else was in there. Colin had always maintained that he'd met his friend Gladys in the city before returning home at around midnight and going straight to bed. His mother, Edie Ross, vouched for this. She recalled that Colin had arrived home at around 7pm, ate dinner, and then went out again. Edie was still up when Colin returned around midnight. He went straight to the bedroom he shared with another of his brothers, Ronald. A military man who'd served overseas, Ronald was a light sleeper who woke at the slightest of noises. He stirred when Colin entered the room and was certain he couldn't have left during the night without waking him. According to prosecution witness Sydney Harding, Colin had confessed to killing Alma in the back room behind the bar before cleaning the scene. Stanley Ross had returned to the Australian wine
里面没有其他人。科林一直坚持说，他在午夜左右回家并直接上床睡觉之前，在城里见了他的朋友格拉迪斯（Gladys）。他的母亲伊迪·罗斯（Edie Ross）为此作证。她回忆说，科林在晚上7点左右到家，吃了晚饭，然后又出去了。科林在午夜左右回来时，伊迪还没睡。他直接去了他和另一个兄弟罗纳德（Ronald）共用的卧室。罗纳德是一名曾在海外服役的军人，睡眠很浅，一点动静就会醒。科林进房间时他被惊醒了，他确信科林晚上不可能在不吵醒他的情况下离开。据控方证人悉尼·哈丁（Sydney Harding）称，科林曾承认在吧台后面的后室杀害了阿尔玛，然后清理了现场。斯坦利·罗斯在周六早上回到澳大利亚葡萄酒
saloon on Saturday morning to prepare for the day's trade. He swept the floor and scrubbed surfaces. There was no indication that the saloon or its back room had been cleaned the previous night. The Ross family testified at trial in support of Colin and corroborated his version of events. Edie described Colin as a good son who was a bit rough around the edges, but certainly not a child killer. Another one of Colin's brothers named Thomas told the court that when the family heard news of Colin's arrest, they found it comical in its absurdity. Thomas explained, I thought that my brother would have been the last man in the world to be detained.
沙龙准备当天的营业。他扫了地，擦洗了表面。没有任何迹象表明沙龙或其后室在前一天晚上被清理过。罗斯一家在审判中作证支持科林，并证实了他的说法。伊迪形容科林是一个好儿子，虽然有点粗鲁，但绝对不是杀童犯。科林的另一个兄弟托马斯（Thomas）告诉法庭，当家人听到科林被捕的消息时，他们觉得这荒谬得可笑。托马斯解释说：“我认为我兄弟是世界上最不可能被拘留的人。”
To outsiders, the Ross family were just protecting one of their own. No one seemed to consider the possibility that they were telling the truth. After Colin's conviction, his family gathered at their home to plot their next move. They agreed without hesitation to mortgage their house to fund an appeal. All of a sudden, there was a knock at the front door. Standing outside was a young woman who introduced herself as Florence Rudkin. She was well aware of the infamous Tershki case. The vicious frenzy it had stirred up in Melbourne had prevented Florence from coming forward sooner, as she wanted no association with it. But with Colin being found guilty, Florence put her personal
对外人来说，罗斯一家只是在保护自己人。没有人考虑过他们说的是真话的可能性。科林被定罪后，他的家人聚集在家里策划下一步行动。他们毫不犹豫地同意抵押房产来筹集上诉资金。突然，前门传来敲门声。站在外面的是一位年轻女子，她自称是弗洛伦斯·鲁德金（Florence Rudkin）。她非常了解臭名昭著的特斯基案。它在墨尔本激起的恶毒狂热使弗洛伦斯无法早点站出来，因为她不想与此案有任何关联。但随着科林被判有罪，弗洛伦斯放下个人
feelings aside to reveal what she knew. At around five on the afternoon of Friday December 30, 1921, Florence had stopped in at the Australian wine saloon. She visited occasionally as it was a quiet establishment where she could be left alone. Florence settled into a dark corner in the parlour. It was an uneventful visit until Olive Maddox dropped in. Boisterous and unsteady, Olive was clearly intoxicated. She stood at the parlor's entrance and examined the room before moving off. Florence was still in the parlor when Olive reappeared an hour later right before closing time. When Florence went to leave, Colin Ross was still there. She caught a glimpse of the private room behind the bar.
感受，揭露了她所知道的情况。1921年12月30日星期五下午5点左右，弗洛伦斯顺道去了澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙。她偶尔会去那里，因为那是一个安静的场所，她可以独自待着。弗洛伦斯在客厅的一个黑暗角落里坐下。这是一次平静的访问，直到奥利夫·马多克斯（Olive Maddox）进来。奥利夫喧闹且脚步不稳，显然喝醉了。她站在客厅入口处，环顾房间，然后走开了。一小时后，就在打烊前，当奥利夫再次出现时，弗洛伦斯还在客厅里。当弗洛伦斯准备离开时，科林·罗斯还在那里。她瞥见了吧台后面的私人房间。
There was no one there. The reason Florence felt it was so important to come forward with this information was that she had flowing red hair. At the time of her visit to the saloon she'd been wearing a hat, just like Alma Tursky. Given that the parlour was dimly lit and Olivmatix had been intoxicated, Florence feared that Oliv had mistaken her for Alma. Stanley Ross had remembered Florence Rudkin as one of their few customers that day. He'd sought her out when his brother was initially detained, but he only knew her as Flori and was unable to track her down. Florence Rudkin was told to take her story to a man named Thomas Brennan. An experienced and
里面没有人。弗洛伦斯觉得提供这些信息如此重要的原因是她有一头飘逸的红发。在她去沙龙时，她戴着一顶帽子，就像阿尔玛·特斯基一样。考虑到客厅光线昏暗，且奥利夫·马迪克斯喝醉了，弗洛伦斯担心奥利夫把她误认成了阿尔玛。斯坦利·罗斯记得弗洛伦斯·鲁德金是那天他们为数不多的顾客之一。在他兄弟最初被拘留时，他曾寻找过她，但他只知道她叫弗洛里（Flori），无法追踪到她。弗洛伦斯·鲁德金被告知将她的故事告诉一个叫托马斯·布伦南（Thomas Brennan）的人。作为一名经验丰富且
formidable criminal attorney, Brennan was one part of Colin's two-man legal team. Brennan was one part of Colin's two-man legal team. Like the Rosses, Brennan was left speechless by Colin's conviction. He'd never doubted the man was innocent, and after hearing the entirety of the prosecution's evidence in person, he couldn't believe the jury had found him guilty beyond reasonable doubt. In the defence's opinion, the prosecution's case was not only absolutely incoherent, but absolutely inconsistent. After detailing all of its flaws and inconsistencies, they were certain Column was going to walk from court a free man. As far as the defence were concerned, the prosecution's star witnesses were a quintent of disreputables. For starters, there was Francis Upton, the man who claimed to have visited the Australian wine saloon after midnight on December 30 to encounter Colin Ross with
令人生畏的刑事律师，布伦南是科林两名辩护律师团队的一员。像罗斯一家一样，布伦南对科林的定罪感到目瞪口呆。他从未怀疑过这个人是无辜的，在亲自听取了控方的全部证据后，他无法相信陪审团竟然在排除合理怀疑的情况下判定他有罪。在辩方看来，控方的案件不仅完全不连贯，而且完全不一致。在详细说明了所有的缺陷和不一致之处后，他们确信科林会作为自由人走出法庭。就辩方而言，控方的主要证人是一群声名狼藉之徒。首先是弗朗西斯·厄普顿（Francis Upton），此人声称在12月30日午夜后访问了澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙，并遇到了双手沾满
blood-stained hands. Francis had also implicated an unidentified woman who he claimed to have heard in the saloon with Colin. Thomas Brennan was incredulous of Francis' testimony from the outset. In Brennan's words, Francis was... A derelict, a drunkard, a wife deserter, a notorious romancer, and convicted criminal. a notorious romancer, and convicted criminal. His rap sheet included charges for larceny, drunkenness, and embezzlement. In court, Francis described himself as a bad character who'd skipped out on his wife and kids and spent all his earnings on alcohol. Brennan hoped the jury would realise that testimony beginning with the witness regaining consciousness in a park after a bender necessitated a considerable degree of scepticism.
鲜血的科林·罗斯。弗朗西斯还牵连了一名身份不明的女子，他声称在沙龙里听到了她和科林在一起。托马斯·布伦南从一开始就对弗朗西斯的证词表示怀疑。用布伦南的话说，弗朗西斯是……“一个流浪汉、酒鬼、抛妻弃子者、臭名昭著的吹牛大王和已定罪的罪犯。”他的犯罪记录包括盗窃、酗酒和贪污指控。在法庭上，弗朗西斯形容自己是一个抛弃了妻子和孩子、把所有收入都花在酒精上的坏人。布伦南希望陪审团能意识到，证词如果始于证人在狂欢后在公园里恢复知觉，那么这就需要相当程度的怀疑。
Francis even admitted during cross-examination that he usually got so drunk he didn't remember anything. In fact, he was such a prolific alcoholic that he had no memories of ever visiting the Australian wine saloon except for on December 30. Francis said he'd learnt of Alma Tursky's murder on January 2, yet he only approached police to implicate Colin Ross after the £1000 reward was offered. Then there were the two jailbirds, Sydney Harding and Joseph Dunstan. Sydney testified that Colin had confessed to killing Elmer while they were in the prison yard. Joseph corroborated this, saying he overheard parts of the confession. Thomas Brennan had explained to the jury why they should be wary of these claims. Sydney and Joseph were convicted criminals with a history including assault, larceny,
弗朗西斯甚至在交叉询问中承认，他通常喝得太醉，什么都不记得了。事实上，他是一个如此多产的酒鬼，以至于除了12月30日那天，他对访问澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙没有任何记忆。弗朗西斯说他在1月2日才得知阿尔玛·特斯基被谋杀的消息，但他只有在1000英镑的悬赏金被提出后才联系警方指控科林·罗斯。然后是两个狱友，悉尼·哈丁（Sydney Harding）和约瑟夫·邓斯坦（Joseph Dunstan）。悉尼作证说，科林在监狱操场时承认杀害了阿尔玛。约瑟夫证实了这一点，说他无意中听到了供词的部分内容。托马斯·布伦南向陪审团解释了他们为什么要对这些说法保持警惕。悉尼和约瑟夫是已定罪的罪犯，有包括袭击、盗窃、
receiving stolen goods and even perjury. Not only were they known to one another, they were on remand for a housebreaking they committed together. Sydney Harding had come forward to the police before the Coronial Inquest, but after the big reward was announced. After establishing himself as a star prosecution witness, Sydney was permitted to leave the confines of jail and to live in far cozier lodgings near the city. It was a fitting prize for a man other prisoners referred to as a dog due to his reputation as a snitch. Colin Ross knew of Sydney's dishonourable notoriety and in no way considered him a friend. Thomas Brennan assumed the jury would realise how comical the whole setup was. Why would his
收受赃物甚至伪证在内的前科。他们不仅彼此认识，而且还因共同犯下的入室盗窃罪而被还押候审。悉尼·哈丁在验尸官调查之前就向警方站了出来，但那是在巨额悬赏宣布之后。在确立了自己作为控方主要证人的地位后，悉尼被允许离开监狱的禁锢，住在离城市更舒适的地方。对于一个因告密名声在外而被其他囚犯称为“狗”的人来说，这是一个合适的奖赏。科林·罗斯知道悉尼卑劣的名声，绝不认为他是朋友。托马斯·布伦南认为陪审团会意识到整个安排是多么可笑。为什么他的
client trust a criminal he barely knew who had a reputation for leaking information to police? During one prison visit, Colin's legal team had warned him, say nothing, they'll plant people in here to testify against you. It made no sense for him to then go and divulge everything about the murder to a random inmate. Joseph Dunstan came forward to police after the coronial inquest, but before the trial. He admitted that he'd spoken to Sydney before making his statement. Both men also revealed that they'd read the Daily Paper together, which featured detailed updates on the Tershki case. These stories included all the evidence, Colin's version of
当事人会信任一个他几乎不认识、且有向警方泄露信息名声的罪犯？在一次监狱探视中，科林的法律团队曾警告他：“什么都别说，他们会在这里安插人手来指证你。”他随后去向一个随机的囚犯泄露关于谋杀案的一切，这根本说不通。约瑟夫·邓斯坦在验尸官调查后、审判前向警方站了出来。他承认在发表声明前曾与悉尼交谈过。两人还透露，他们一起阅读了《每日报》（Daily Paper），上面有关于特斯基案的详细更新。这些报道包括了所有证据、科林的说法，
events, and the allegations other witnesses had made against him. Another prisoner on remand with the two witnesses claimed that he'd overheard Sydney tell Joseph, I have told you about Ross and I will fix you up after the trial. Thomas Brennan knew better than most that assertions made by prison snitches should be considered with extreme caution. Sydney and Joseph had proven themselves liars in the past, pleading innocent for crimes they were ultimately found guilty of. Criminals usually didn't help the police unless there was something in it for them. The jury were told to consider the likelihood the pair were offered a deal to testify against Colin. As for Ivy Matthews, the former bartender who claimed to have seen Alma Tursky drinking in the private room behind the bar of the Australian wine saloon, the defence had some serious doubts
以及其他证人对他提出的指控。另一名与这两名证人一起还押的囚犯声称，他无意中听到悉尼对约瑟夫说：“我已经告诉过你关于罗斯的事了，审判结束后我会帮你解决。”托马斯·布伦南比大多数人更清楚，监狱告密者的断言应极其谨慎地对待。悉尼和约瑟夫过去已被证明是骗子，对他们最终被判有罪的罪行拒不认罪。罪犯通常不会帮助警察，除非这对他们有好处。陪审团被告知要考虑两人被提供交易以指证科的可能性。至于艾薇·马修斯（Ivy Matthews），那位声称看到阿尔玛·特斯基在澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙吧台后的私人房间里喝酒的前调酒师，辩方对
about her story. Ivy was first interviewed by detectives almost a week after Alma's body was discovered. At that time, Ivy said she hadn't seen Alma and knew nothing about what had happened to her. It was only weeks later that she came forward to police with her story implicating Colin Ross in the crime. When asked why she hadn't revealed this pertinent information during her first interview, Ivy said as a former employee of Colin's she felt a degree of loyalty to him. Both Ivy Matthews and Olive Maddux claimed to have seen a girl matching Alma Tursky's description drinking at the saloon on the afternoon of December 30. Colin had allegedly confessed to giving Alma upwards of three glasses of wine prior to the
她的故事有一些严重的怀疑。艾薇是在阿尔玛的尸体被发现近一周后首次接受侦探采访的。当时，艾薇说她没有见过阿尔玛，也不知道她发生了什么事。直到几周后，她才带着指控科林·罗斯犯罪的故事向警方站了出来。当被问及为什么在第一次采访时没有透露这些相关信息时，艾薇说作为科林的前雇员，她对他有一种忠诚感。艾薇·马修斯和奥利夫·马多克斯都声称在12月30日下午看到一个符合阿尔玛·特斯基特征的女孩在沙龙喝酒。科林据称承认在袭击前给了阿尔玛三杯以上的葡萄酒。
attack. However, Alma's stomach had been examined post-mortem for traces of alcohol, and none were found. During Colin's trial, the defence pointed out that both Ivy and Doleve had added more damning claims against Colin every time they were interviewed. Not only did they come forward after the £1000 reward was on offer, they also revealed key information only when the same information had just been reported by the press. Ivy and Olive were long-time friends who admitted to having discussed the case on multiple occasions before and after Colin's arrest. As far as the defence were concerned, the two women had colluded to falsely accuse Colin in a bid to claim the reward money. While the women claimed that they were
然而，阿尔玛的胃在死后被检查过是否有酒精痕迹，结果什么也没发现。在科林的审判期间，辩方指出，艾薇和奥利夫每次接受采访时都会增加更多针对科林的定罪指控。她们不仅是在1000英镑悬赏金提供后才站出来的，而且只有在媒体刚刚报道了同样的信息时，她们才透露关键信息。艾薇和奥利夫是多年的朋友，她们承认在科林被捕前后曾多次讨论过此案。就辩方而言，这两名女子串通一气，虚假指控科林，企图骗取悬赏金。虽然这两名女子声称她们与科林
amicable with Colin, he said otherwise. Olive and Colin had a temperamental history with one another and hadn't spoken for months. Meanwhile, Ivy had been aggressively demanding money from him that she felt was owed to her. She was also bitter about having lost her job at the saloon, with Colin asserting that Ivy would, quote, do anything for spite to this episode's sponsors. This episode of Casefile is sponsored by BetterHelp. Feeling tired or worn out lately? Perhaps you're struggling to set boundaries or spreading yourself too thin? It's easy to overlook our social battery and overextend ourselves, especially when juggling social events and work commitments. So how much socialising is right for
关系友好，但他却说并非如此。奥利夫和科林之间有易怒的历史，已经几个月没说话了。与此同时，艾薇一直咄咄逼人地向他索要她认为他欠她的钱。她还因为失去了在沙龙的工作而感到痛苦，科林断言艾薇会“为了泄愤做任何事”。本集节目的赞助商。本集《案件档案》（Casefile）由BetterHelp赞助。最近感到疲倦或精疲力竭了吗？也许你正在努力设定界限或让自己负担过重？很容易忽视我们的社交能量并过度透支自己，尤其是在兼顾社交活动和工作承诺时。那么多少社交才适合
you, and how do you recharge? Whether you thrive around people or need more time alone, therapy can help you understand your needs and build a social life that doesn't drain you. It teaches helpful coping skills and boundary setting, empowering anyone to be their best self, not just those who've faced major trauma. If you're thinking of starting therapy, consider trying BetterHelp. It's entirely online, designed for convenience and tailored to fit your schedule. Just fill out a short questionnaire to be matched with a licensed therapist and you can switch therapists at any time at no extra cost. Find your social sweet spot with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash case file today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp, h-e-L-P dot com slash case file. Many of us dread the nightly question,
你，你又该如何充电呢？无论你是喜欢与人相处还是需要更多独处时间，治疗都可以帮助你了解自己的需求，并建立一种不会让你精疲力竭的社交生活。它教授有用的应对技巧和设定界限的方法，赋予任何人成为最好的自己的能力，而不仅仅是那些经历过重大创伤的人。如果你正在考虑开始治疗，请考虑尝试BetterHelp。它完全在线，专为方便而设计，并根据你的日程安排量身定制。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，你可以随时免费更换治疗师。通过BetterHelp找到你的社交最佳状态。今天访问betterhelp.com/casefile，首次购买可享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp，h-e-l-p点com斜杠casefile。我们许多人都害怕每晚的那个问题，
what's for dinner? I know I do. It's too easy to just order takeout, but it's not satisfying and costs way too much. Home Chef makes it simple and saves you money so you can enjoy homemade meals without the stress. Home Chef provides fresh ingredients and chef-designed recipes conveniently delivered to your doorstep to simplify your cooking experience. And they've got options for every kind of cook. There are classic meal kits with pre-portioned ingredients and easy instructions, oven-ready kits with pre-chopped ingredients, and quick microwave meals that assemble in minutes. Home Chef has over 30 options a week and serves a variety of dietary needs, so you don't have
晚餐吃什么？我知道我怕。点外卖太容易了，但既不满足又太贵。Home Chef让一切变得简单，为你省钱，让你无需压力即可享受家常菜。Home Chef提供新鲜食材和厨师设计的食谱，方便地送到你家门口，简化你的烹饪体验。他们为各种厨师提供了选择。有带有预分量食材和简单说明的经典餐包，有带有预切食材的烤箱即食包，还有几分钟内即可组装的快速微波炉餐。Home Chef每周有超过30种选择，满足各种饮食需求，所以你不需要
to worry about what to make ahead of time. Not only is it convenient, but it's economical too. Home Chef customers save an average of $86 per month on groceries. Olivia LaVoice, host of Casefile Presents series The Bakersfield 3, is loving Home Chef for its convenience and the high quality of the ingredients supplied. She says it's also introduced her to new recipes she wouldn't have otherwise made. For a limited time, Home Chef is offering our listeners 18 free meals plus free dessert for life and of course, free shipping on your first box.
提前担心要做什么。它不仅方便，而且经济。Home Chef客户平均每月在杂货上节省86美元。《案件档案》系列《贝克斯菲尔德3》（The Bakersfield 3）的主持人奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯（Olivia LaVoice）非常喜欢Home Chef的便利性和所提供食材的高品质。她说它还向她介绍了她原本不会做的新食谱。在有限的时间内，Home Chef为我们的听众提供18份免费餐点，外加终身免费甜点，当然，还有首个餐盒免费送货。
Go to homechef.com slash case file. That's homechef.com slash case file for 18 free meals and free dessert for life. You heard that right. HomeChef.com slash Casefile. Must be an active subscriber to receive free dessert. This episode of Casefile is brought to you by NordVPN. Picture this. You're itching to catch that exclusive sports event, binge-watch your
前往homechef.com/casefile。那是homechef.com/casefile，可获得18份免费餐点和终身免费甜点。你没听错。HomeChef.com/Casefile。必须是活跃订阅者才能获得免费甜点。本集《案件档案》由NordVPN为您带来。想象一下。你渴望观看那场独家体育赛事，狂看你
favourite TV show, or indulge in a cinematic masterpiece. But alas, it's not available in your region. Fear not. With NordVPN, you can transcend geographical boundaries by switching your virtual location to a country where your desired content is available. It's like having a magic portal to a world of endless entertainment. But NordVPN isn't just about unlocking restricted content. It's a fortress for your private data, safeguarding your bank details, passwords, and online identity from prying eyes. And here's the kicker. By masking your virtual location,
最喜欢的电视节目，或沉浸在电影杰作中。但遗憾的是，它在你的地区不可用。别担心。有了NordVPN，你可以通过将虚拟位置切换到你想要的内容可用的国家来跨越地理界限。这就像拥有通往无尽娱乐世界的魔法门。但NordVPN不仅仅是关于解锁受限内容。它是你私人数据的堡垒，保护你的银行详细信息、密码和在线身份免受窥探。最棒的是，通过掩盖你的虚拟位置，
NordVPN can also help you save money. You can snag cheaper flights, hotels and subscriptions from other countries. NordVPN also has your back with the threat protection feature, which shields you from viruses, malware and phishing sites. So whether you're at home or trotting the globe, it's like having a personal bodyguard for your digital life, all for no more than a cup of coffee per month. To get the best discount off your Nord VPN plan, go to nordvpn.com slash caseile. Our link will also give you four extra months on the two-year plan. There's no risk with Nord's 30-day money-back guarantee. The link is in the podcast episode description box.
NordVPN还可以帮助你省钱。你可以从其他国家抢购更便宜的机票、酒店和订阅。NordVPN还通过威胁防护功能为你提供支持，该功能可以保护你免受病毒、恶意软件和钓鱼网站的侵害。因此，无论你是在家还是环游世界，它都像为你数字生活配备的私人保镖，每月费用不超过一杯咖啡。要获得Nord VPN计划的最佳折扣，请前往nordvpn.com/casefile。我们的链接还将为你提供两年计划的额外四个月服务。Nord的30天退款保证让你没有风险。链接在播客剧集描述框中。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. As The Defence pointed out, the only moments where the five key witnesses' stories aligned was when they were presenting information that had been published in the papers. The other mysteries of the case, such as how exactly Alma came to be in the saloon and how her body was disposed of, conflicted between accounts. Colin had allegedly told Ivy that Alma approached him and asked for a drink. In Sydney's version of events, it was Colin who coaxed the girl into his saloon. Ivy said she'd seen Alma in the room behind the bar at 3pm, while Olive said she saw Alma at 5pm in the parlour. In Ivy's version, Alma was awake and alert when the attack commenced. In Sydney's account, Alma was unconscious. Ivy said Colin had driven
感谢收听本集广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，你支持《案件档案》继续提供高质量的内容。正如辩方所指出的，五位关键证人的故事唯一吻合的时刻是他们提供报纸上已经发布的信息时。案件的其他谜团，例如阿尔玛究竟是如何进入沙龙的以及她的尸体是如何处理的，在不同证词之间存在冲突。科林据称告诉艾薇，阿尔玛走近他并要求喝一杯。在悉尼的版本中，是科林诱骗女孩进入他的沙龙。艾薇说她在下午3点看到阿尔玛在吧台后面的房间里，而奥利夫说她在下午5点在客厅看到阿尔玛。在艾薇的版本中，袭击开始时阿尔玛是清醒且警觉的。在悉尼的描述中，阿尔玛是昏迷的。艾薇说科林
back to the city in the early hours, while Sydney claimed he rode a bicycle. Depending on the witness, Alma's body was either driven or carried to Gunn Alley. The timings of all these happenings conflicted, and when taken as a whole, were completely incoherent. Collins alleged descriptions of Alma also didn't add up. Those who knew Alma best said she was a shy and naive girl with a quiet temperament. Accounts from the so-called quintet of disreputals had Colin saying Alma was a cheeky little devil who demanded alcohol, was forthright with men and sexually active. The defence felt there was no way Colin could
在凌晨开车回城，而悉尼声称他骑自行车。根据证人的不同，阿尔玛的尸体要么是被开车运走，要么是被搬运到枪巷。所有这些事件的时间安排相互冲突，综合来看，完全不连贯。科林对阿尔玛的所谓描述也站不住脚。那些最了解阿尔玛的人说她是一个害羞、天真、性格安静的女孩。来自所谓“声名狼藉五人组”的描述称，科林说阿尔玛是一个要求喝酒、对男人直率且性活跃的“厚脸皮小恶魔”。辩方认为科林绝不可能
have interacted with Alma and come away with such an inaccurate character assessment. None of this even took into account the assertions of other witnesses. Sixty other customers visited the Australian Wine Saloon on December 30. Based on the statements provided by Olive Maddix and Divy Matthews, Alma was in the saloon for upwards of three hours that afternoon. Yet, aside from those two women, no one else saw her. Two patrons said they'd shared a drink with Colin Ross and his brother Stanley in the room behind the bar and remained there until closing time. They could say with utmost confidence that Alma Tursky was not with them. These men along with the other saloon patrons went to the police and vouched for Colin, unanimously stating that he was at the saloon between 2pm and closing time on December 30. They remembered him helping his
与阿尔玛互动后得出如此不准确的性格评估。所有这些甚至没有考虑到其他证人的断言。12月30日，有60名其他顾客访问了澳大利亚葡萄酒沙龙。根据奥利夫·马迪克斯和艾薇·马修斯提供的陈述，阿尔玛那天下午在沙龙里待了三个多小时。然而，除了那两名女子外，没有其他人看到她。两名顾客说他们曾与科林·罗斯和他的兄弟斯坦利在吧台后面的房间里喝过酒，并一直待到打烊。他们可以极其自信地说，阿尔玛·特斯基没有和他们在一起。这些人连同其他沙龙顾客一起去警察局为科林作证，一致声明他在12月30日下午2点到打烊期间一直待在沙龙里。他们记得他帮他
brother behind the bar and chatting to customers. Ivy Matthews claimed it was the following day of December 31 that Colin led her out of the saloon and onto Little Collins Street where he confessed to Elmer's murder. But other patrons, including Florence Rugkin, had been in the saloon at the time. At no point did they see Ivy Matthews there, nor did Colin leave the building at any time. At no point did they see Ivy Matthews there, nor did Colin leave the building at any time. If he disappeared from view, it was for barely minutes at a time. According to Olive Maddix, Colin had made suspicious comments to her about the Tershki case on January 5. But multiple witnesses asserted that Colin was socialising at a home in West Melbourne that day, and Doleve wasn't there. In the lead up to and during the trial, each of the prosecution's
兄弟在吧台后面工作并与顾客聊天。艾薇·马修斯声称是12月31日的第二天，科林把她带出沙龙来到小柯林斯街，在那里他承认了谋杀阿尔玛。但包括弗洛伦斯·鲁德金在内的其他顾客当时也在沙龙里。他们从未在任何时候看到艾薇·马修斯在那里，科林也没有在任何时候离开过大楼。如果他从视线中消失，那也几乎不到几分钟。据奥利夫·马迪克斯称，科林在1月5日曾对她发表过关于特斯基案的可疑评论。但多名证人断言，科林那天在西墨尔本的一个家里社交，而奥利夫并不在那里。在审判前和审判期间，每一位控方
witnesses were paid sustenance payments which rewarded witness cooperation. Post-conviction, they were each eligible to receive a share of the £1,000 reward. Thomas Brennan hoped the jury would realise the danger of hinging a man's life or death on conflicting circumstantial evidence. Yet, even if the jury had dismissed the witnesses' claims, there was still the matter of the prosecution's smoking gun, Alma's hairs found on the blankets from Colin's saloon. This was concrete evidence that she'd been there, the kind of evidence that was impervious to deceit, pressure or influence. Or was it? When the saloon closed down after failing to secure a new liquor license, most of its contents were taken to the Ross family home in Footscray, including the two blankets from
证人都获得了奖励证人合作的维持费。定罪后，他们每人都有资格获得1000英镑悬赏金的份额。托马斯·布伦南希望陪审团能意识到将一个人的生死悬于相互冲突的间接证据之上的危险。然而，即使陪审团驳回了证人的说法，仍然存在控方的“确凿证据”——在科林沙龙的毯子上发现的阿尔玛的头发。这是她曾在那里过的具体证据，这种证据不受欺骗、压力或影响。或者真的是这样吗？当沙龙因未能获得新的酒牌而关闭时，其大部分物品被带到了位于富茨克雷（Footscray）的罗斯家中，包括来自
the back room, one brown, one blue. The blankets were often laid out on the veranda for guests to sit on. At no point did Colin's mother Edie see any long red hairs on them. If there were any, she believed they'd likely come from a redheaded female relative who had been staying over. When the blankets were taken into police custody, they weren't secured in any way to avoid contamination. After being freely transported in a police car, they were left on a detective's desk for an extended period of time until the analyst was ready to examine them. The Ross trial marked the first conviction in Australasia using a scientific comparison of hairs, and it was not as reliable as it seemed. The analysis was done on appearance alone. The analyst who performed the comparison was a chemist by trade. He had no expert
后室的两条毯子，一条棕色，一条蓝色。毯子经常铺在阳台上供客人坐。科林的母亲伊迪在任何时候都没有看到上面有任何长红发。如果有的话，她认为它们很可能是来自一位曾留宿的红发女性亲戚。当毯子被警方拘留时，它们没有以任何方式被保护以避免污染。在被随意地用警车运输后，它们被留在侦探的桌子上很长一段时间，直到分析师准备好检查它们。罗斯案的审判标志着澳大拉西亚首次使用头发的科学比对进行定罪，而且它并不像看起来那么可靠。分析仅凭外观进行。进行比对的分析师是一名化学家。他没有头发分析方面的专家
knowledge in hair analysis and had never previously analysed any hair samples. While the hairs were all red in colour, they varied in tone, length and texture. Colin admitted to bringing women into the saloon's back room. Two red-haired women even testified to having combed their hair while in there, using a mirror which hung above the couch where the blankets were laid. Gladys, the friend Colin brought to his saloon on the night of December 30, also had red hair. Had the hairs been forcefully pulled from someone's scalp, one would expect they would still contain their roots. However, only one of the hairs still had its root attached. In the state they were found in, the hairs aligned more with having fallen out naturally, not forcefully. The one root the
知识，也从未分析过任何头发样本。虽然头发颜色都是红色的，但它们在色调、长度和质地上各不相同。科林承认带女人进入沙龙的后室。两名红发女子甚至作证说，她们在里面时曾梳过头发，使用的是挂在毯子铺设的沙发上方的镜子。科林在12月30日晚上带到沙龙的朋友格拉迪斯也有红头发。如果头发是从某人的头皮上强行拔下的，人们会期望它们仍然包含毛囊。然而，只有一根头发仍然附着着毛囊。在发现它们的状态下，头发更符合自然脱落，而不是强行脱落。分析师拥有的那一个毛囊
analyst did have was essentially useless. He couldn't compare it to the sample of Alma's hair as it had been cut six inches from her scalp and therefore didn't have any roots attached either. The analyst concluded that all the hairs had come from Alma. But without a form of testing that could prove it, his findings were nothing more than personal opinion. Colin had initially identified the brown blanket where 22 of the red hairs were found as having been inside his saloon, but he later realised that he'd confused it with another blanket. He now claimed that the one taken in as evidence had never been in his saloon. When shown the exhibit, even former bartender Ivy Matthews said she'd never seen that blanket before. Seamen stains found on the blue blanket
基本上毫无用处。他无法将其与阿尔玛的头发样本进行比对，因为它是从她头皮六英寸处剪下的，因此也没有附着任何毛囊。分析师得出结论，所有的头发都来自阿尔玛。但如果没有一种能证明这一点的测试形式，他的发现只不过是个人观点。科林最初确认发现22根红头发的棕色毯子曾在他的沙龙里，但他后来意识到他把它与另一条毯子搞混了。他现在声称作为证据被带走的那条毯子从未在他的沙龙里出现过。当被展示该证物时，连前调酒师艾薇·马修斯也说她以前从未见过那条毯子。在蓝色毯子上发现的精液污渍
were deemed evidence that Colin had raped Daumer. However, when the blanket was kept at the Ross House, several of Colin's brothers had sprawled on it with their girlfriends. There was no way to test who the seaman originated from. The torn up blue fabric allegedly found on Footscray Road before Colin's trial wasn't a reliable piece of evidence either. It had been given weight because it supported Sydney Harding's statement that Collins shredded Elmer's clothing and scattered the pieces at that location after her murder. The piece of fabric was never proven to have originated from Elmer's clothing. It was also surprisingly clean considering it had allegedly been on the side of a busy road for
被视为科林强奸阿尔玛的证据。然而，当毯子存放在罗斯家时，科林的几个兄弟曾和他们的女朋友在上面躺过。没有办法测试精液源自谁。在科林审判前据称在富茨克雷路（Footscray Road）发现的撕碎的蓝色织物也不是可靠的证据。它之所以被赋予权重，是因为它支持了悉尼·哈丁的陈述，即科林在谋杀阿尔玛后撕碎了她的衣服并将碎片散落在该地点。这块织物从未被证明源自阿尔玛的衣服。考虑到它据称在繁忙的道路边待了
months. Furthermore, the police had never even bothered to search the area where it was recovered. Given the hoaxes that had arisen around Gunn Alley, it wasn't outrageous to consider that the fabric could have been planted there. In any case, if Sydney's statement was a lie, as the defence argued, the fabric held no relevance at all. Even if Colin Ross had killed Alma Tershky, in each alleged version of the crime, the manner in which the death occurred was described as accidental, not deliberate. Ivy Matthews' original statement even contained the line, Colin did not intend to kill her, a crucial point she failed to repeat a trial. The defence felt that even if the confessions were true, Colin should have been charged with the
几个月，它竟然出奇地干净。此外，警方甚至从未费心搜查过发现它的区域。考虑到枪巷周围出现的恶作剧，认为织物可能是被栽赃的并非不可理喻。无论如何，如果悉尼的陈述是谎言，正如辩方所辩称的那样，这块织物根本没有任何关联。即使科林·罗斯确实杀害了阿尔玛·特斯基，在每一种所谓的犯罪版本中，死亡发生的方式都被描述为意外，而非蓄意。艾薇·马修斯的原始陈述甚至包含这样一行：“科林无意杀她”，这是她在审判中未能重复的一个关键点。辩方认为，即使供词是真的，科林也应该被指控为
lesser crime of manslaughter. With all this in mind, Thomas Brennan couldn't believe Colin Ross was handed a guilty verdict for murder. Expressing an opinion that was ahead of its time, Brennan believed the jury were unconsciously swayed by the sensational and salacious press. Their articles inflamed public perception of Colin the moment he entered the investigation. In Brennan's opinion, his client came into the dock convicted. He said, Never in the history of serious crimes in Victoria, or indeed in the British Empire, has a man been convicted on such a jumbled mass of contradictions. The only explanation is that the jury quite unconsciously formed opinions before they went
较轻的过失杀人罪。考虑到所有这些，托马斯·布伦南无法相信科林·罗斯被判谋杀罪成立。布伦南表达了一种超前的观点，认为陪审团在潜意识里受到了耸人听闻和淫秽媒体的影响。他们的文章在科林进入调查的那一刻就激化了公众对他的看法。在布伦南看来，他的当事人进入被告席时就已经被定罪了。他说：“在维多利亚州，甚至在大英帝国的严重犯罪史上，从未有人在如此混乱的矛盾堆积中被定罪。唯一的解释是，陪审团在进入陪审席之前就无意识地形成了观点，并且由于他们的判断被自然的义愤所蒙蔽，他们无法冷静地看待此事。”
into the box and, with their judgements clouded by their natural indignation, they were unable to view the matter dispassionately. In the months following Collins' trial, several jurors spoke anonymously with the Herald newspaper. One said that during proceedings he'd locked eyes with Colin who quickly averted his gaze. This one fleeting action led the juror to conclude that Colin was a guilty man. Another said there was a fear among the jury of speaking critically about the evidence presented against Colin in case, quote, the hand of public scorn might point them out forever. He admitted that the jury had disregarded the claims by prosecution witness Francis Upton,
在科林审判后的几个月里，几名陪审员匿名接受了《先驱报》（Herald）的采访。其中一人说，在诉讼过程中，他曾与科林目光接触，科林迅速移开了视线。这一个短暂的动作导致该陪审员得出结论，科林是一个有罪的人。另一人说，陪审团中存在一种恐惧，不敢对针对科林提出的证据进行批评，以防“公众蔑视之手可能永远指向他们”。他承认陪审团无视了控方证人弗朗西斯·厄普顿的说法，
and there was scattered support for the others. The majority believed Ivy Matthews, but only half believed Sydney Harding. The guilty verdict would have been reached in minutes had it not been for two jurors expressing doubts that dragged the process out. One of the dissenting jurors was an elderly man who broke down in tears when the verdict was read out in court. Another became emotional once he got home, saying, I never want to serve on another jury charged with having to decide on a man's fate again. The defence had presented all the points justifying Colin's innocence during the trial and still lost.
其他人则得到了零星的支持。大多数人相信艾薇·马修斯（Ivy Matthews），但只有一半人相信悉尼·哈丁（Sydney Harding）。如果不是两名陪审员表达了疑虑并拖延了进程，有罪判决本可在几分钟内做出。其中一名持异议的陪审员是一位老者，当法庭宣读判决时，他泪流满面。另一名陪审员回家后情绪激动，他说：“我再也不想担任任何需要决定他人命运的陪审员了。”辩方在审判期间提出了所有证明科林（Colin）无罪的论点，但最终还是败诉了。
They couldn't pursue an appeal with the same information. With Florence Rudkin coming forward post-conviction, Thomas Brennan had something new to work with. And Florence wasn't the only one. Prompted by the conviction, taxi driver Joseph Graham came forward to Colin Ross' legal team to detail his story about hearing a young girl screaming on Little Collins Street on the afternoon of Friday December 30 1921. Although the police had been aware of this information and a second witness from Ballarat had corroborated it, this was the first time the defence had ever heard of it. While detectives had taken notes, they never followed up with either of the men,
他们无法利用同样的信息提起上诉。随着弗洛伦斯·鲁德金（Florence Rudkin）在定罪后站出来，托马斯·布伦南（Thomas Brennan）有了新的线索。而且弗洛伦斯并不是唯一一个。受定罪消息的触动，出租车司机约瑟夫·格雷厄姆（Joseph Graham）向科林·罗斯（Colin Ross）的法律团队详细讲述了他于1921年12月30日星期五下午在小柯林斯街（Little Collins Street）听到一个小女孩尖叫的故事。尽管警方早已知晓这一信息，且第二名来自巴拉瑞特（Ballarat）的证人也证实了这一点，但这却是辩方第一次听说。虽然侦探们做了记录，但他们从未跟进这两名男子的线索，
nor were further investigations made into the claims. The information was never given to the press to see if anyone else could elaborate on it. Neither Joseph Graham nor the man from Ballarat were contacted to participate in the coronial inquest or murder trial relating to Alma Turski's death. To critics of the investigation, the men's exclusion highlighted the detective's attitude towards evidence that vindicated Colin. The level of disinterest from authorities about these witness accounts resulted in the name and contact details of the Ballarat man getting misplaced. Thomas Brennan took chief responsibility for appealing Colin's verdict. When he made the application, he asked the Court of Criminal Appeal for time. After all, two new and extraordinary witnesses had come forward
也没有对这些说法进行进一步调查。这些信息从未提供给媒体，以查看是否还有其他人能提供更多细节。约瑟夫·格雷厄姆和那名来自巴拉瑞特的男子都没有被联系参加关于阿尔玛·特斯基（Alma Turski）死亡的死因研讯或谋杀案审判。对于调查的批评者来说，这两名男子的被排除凸显了侦探对证明科林清白的证据所持的态度。当局对这些证人证词的漠不关心，导致那名巴拉瑞特男子的姓名和联系方式被弄丢了。托马斯·布伦南承担了为科林判决上诉的主要责任。当他提出申请时，他请求刑事上诉法院给予时间。毕竟，两位新的、非同寻常的证人已经站了出来，
and he needed to investigate their claims thoroughly. The judges weren't willing to hold up proceedings to allow such investigations to take place. Brennan told them, surely in a case of life and death time should be given to prepare the appeal. in a case of life and death, time should be given to prepare the appeal. His request was denied and the appeal was scheduled to take place one week later. Colin Ross appeared for the four day hearing. He was worn as he hadn't been sleeping and was in a constant state of anxiety. As a man on death row, he was isolated from other prisoners and was only let out into the yard when it was empty. From there, he had a full view of the gallows. Due to the lack of preparation time, Thomas Brennan wasn't able to schedule all the witnesses he'd intended to present at
他需要彻底调查他们的说法。法官们不愿为了进行此类调查而推迟诉讼程序。布伦南告诉他们，在生死攸关的案件中，理应给予时间准备上诉。在生死攸关的案件中，理应给予时间准备上诉。他的请求被拒绝，上诉被安排在一周后进行。科林·罗斯出席了为期四天的听证会。他显得很憔悴，因为他一直没能入睡，处于持续的焦虑状态。作为一名死囚，他被与其他囚犯隔离开来，只有在院子空着的时候才被允许出去。从那里，他可以清楚地看到绞刑架。由于缺乏准备时间，托马斯·布伦南无法安排他原计划在
Collins' appeal. He had to work with what he had, hoping it would be enough. During the appeal process, a third new witness approached the Ross family. His name was George Crilley and he'd been motivated to come forward after reading about Collins' ordeal and the implication of police suppression and manipulation of evidence. George claimed that on the afternoon of Friday December 30 1921, he was walking up Little Collins Street between 1.30 and 1.45 pm when he noticed a girl matching Alma Tursky's description. A man was following uncomfortably close behind her, so much so that George felt an urge to confront him. A short time later, George's attention was drawn to the facade of the Eastern Arcade.
科林的上诉中出庭的所有证人。他不得不利用现有的资源，希望这足够了。在上诉过程中，第三位新证人联系了罗斯一家。他的名字叫乔治·克里利（George Crilley），在读到科林的遭遇以及警方压制和操纵证据的暗示后，他决定站出来。乔治声称，1921年12月30日星期五下午，他在下午1点30分到1点45分之间沿小柯林斯街行走时，注意到一个符合阿尔玛·特斯基特征的女孩。一名男子紧跟在她身后，距离近得让人不舒服，以至于乔治有一种想要去质问他的冲动。不久之后，乔治的注意力被东拱廊（Eastern Arcade）的门面吸引了。
The man and girl were standing there together, talking. George didn't know who the man was, but it wasn't Colin Ross. George had given this information to police during their investigations and was questioned several times over the matter, but nothing further was done. When Thomas Brennan informed the Court of Criminal Appeal of George Crilley's story, the Chief Justice replied, There is nothing remarkable in somebody seen talking to a little girl.'" Brennan argued otherwise, and while the judges agreed to consider George's statement, they decided that they'd hear no further evidence and immediately retired to consider their verdict.
那个男人和女孩站在那里交谈。乔治不知道那个男人是谁，但那不是科林·罗斯。乔治在警方调查期间提供了这些信息，并就此事接受了多次询问，但没有采取任何进一步行动。当托马斯·布伦南将乔治·克里利的故事告知刑事上诉法院时，首席法官回答说：“看到有人与小女孩交谈并没有什么特别之处。”布伦南据理力争，虽然法官们同意考虑乔治的陈述，但他们决定不再听取任何进一步的证据，并立即退庭商议判决。
When it was time to make their announcement, the Chief Justice stated that it was not part of the court's function to put aside the verdict of a jury unless a miscarriage of justice could be proven. With that, he announced that Colin Ross' appeal was denied. Colin sat quietly while his mother and Florence Rugkin sobbed behind him. Colin was taken back to prison to await his death sentence. Thomas Brennan filed a new appeal, this time with the High Court. The proceedings commenced just weeks before Colin was due to be executed. The High Court judges respected the jury's decision and rejected most of the grounds brought forth by the defence. One judge acknowledged that while Collins' two alleged confessions varied in facts, both ultimately had him admit to raping and killing Alma Tursky.
当宣布判决时，首席法官表示，除非能证明司法不公，否则推翻陪审团的裁决不是法院的职能。随后，他宣布科林·罗斯的上诉被驳回。科林静静地坐着，而他的母亲和弗洛伦斯·鲁德金在他身后啜泣。科林被带回监狱等待死刑。托马斯·布伦南提起了新的上诉，这次是向高等法院。诉讼程序在科林被处决前几周开始。高等法院法官尊重陪审团的决定，驳回了辩方提出的大部分理由。一位法官承认，虽然科林的两份所谓供词在事实上有出入，但最终都承认他强奸并杀害了阿尔玛·特斯基。
Quote, "...if there is any inconsistency, it is an inconsistency in the prisoner's statement, not any inconsistency in the evidence of the witnesses to the alleged confessions. The High Court, by a majority of four to one, rejected the motion for a retrial. Colin cried out, cried out, I am innocent and if they hang me they will hang an innocent man. Edie Ross sold the family home to fund her son's appeals. She fought desperately for his life, taking her campaign all the way to high-ranking religious leaders, politicians and even the Attorney General. She brought along a bundle of letters from sympathetic members of the public and a petition against Colin's conviction with 2000 signatures of support.
引用：“……如果存在任何不一致，那是囚犯陈述中的不一致，而不是所谓供词证人的证据中存在任何不一致。”高等法院以四比一的多数票驳回了重审动议。科林大喊道：“我是无辜的，如果他们绞死我，他们绞死的就是一个无辜的人。”伊迪·罗斯（Edie Ross）卖掉了家里的房子来资助儿子的上诉。她拼命为儿子的生命而战，将她的请愿活动一直带到了高级宗教领袖、政治家甚至总检察长那里。她带来了一捆来自公众同情者的信件，以及一份有2000人签名支持的反对科林定罪的请愿书。
The public perception of Colin was shifting. As a result of their actions post trial, the integrity of the prosecution's star witnesses were being questioned. Having essentially been identified as a grifter, Frank Upton adopted an alias and fled the state fearing retribution from Collins supporters. Sydney Harding and Joseph Dunston were convicted of their joint housebreaking charge, though Sydney was granted early release and Joseph was pardoned. This added credence to the theory the men were offered deals to testify against Colin Ross. Olive Maddox wound up imprisoned
公众对科林的看法正在转变。由于他们在审判后的行为，控方明星证人的诚信受到了质疑。弗兰克·厄普顿（Frank Upton）基本上已被认定为骗子，他改名换姓并逃离了该州，担心遭到科林支持者的报复。悉尼·哈丁和约瑟夫·邓斯顿（Joseph Dunston）因共同入室盗窃罪被定罪，尽管悉尼获得了提前释放，约瑟夫也获得了赦免。这增加了人们对这两人被提供交易以作证指控科林·罗斯的理论的信任度。奥利夫·马多克斯（Olive Maddox）最终因
for sex work and drunkenness. Ivy Matthews gave an interview to the Midnight Sun newspaper about the Tersky case that was full of inaccuracies, with the publication concluding, The question of to what extent Matthews can be relied on, either in speaking of herself or others, is a very open one indeed. While most Australians still believed in Collins' guilt, some felt capital punishment should be reserved for the most cold-blooded and calculated offenders. Letters were sent to the governor seeking mercy for Colin, while others asked that he at least be given a proper opportunity to prove his innocence. Edie Ross was nevertheless fighting an uphill battle. When she told one politician,
从事性工作和醉酒被监禁。艾薇·马修斯就特斯基案接受了《午夜太阳报》（Midnight Sun）的采访，内容充满了不准确之处，该出版物总结道：“马修斯在谈论自己或他人时能在多大程度上被信任，这确实是一个非常开放的问题。”虽然大多数澳大利亚人仍然相信科林有罪，但一些人认为死刑应该留给最冷血和处心积虑的罪犯。人们写信给总督请求宽恕科林，而另一些人则要求至少给他一个证明自己清白的机会。尽管如此，伊迪·罗斯仍在进行一场艰苦的斗争。当她告诉一位政治家时，
less fighting an uphill battle. When she told one politician, my boy is as innocent as me, the politician responded, I am perfectly satisfied that you are wasting your time and money. She managed to get the Attorney General to acknowledge there were weaknesses in the prosecution's case, but he refused to halt the execution. On the morning of, Colin's family went to see him one last time. They struggled to find any words, but Colin was talkative and appeared accepting of his fate. He expressed his gratitude for their belief in him and encouraged them to live on without him. His mother reassured him that she'd continue to fight for him until her last breath. She wasn't permitted to hug Colin, so the brief meeting ended with an unceremonious,
进行一场艰苦的斗争。当她告诉一位政治家：“我的孩子和我一样无辜，”那位政治家回答说：“我完全确信你在浪费时间和金钱。”她设法让总检察长承认控方的案件存在弱点，但他拒绝停止处决。在科林被处决的当天早上，他的家人最后一次去看他。他们努力寻找言语，但科林很健谈，似乎接受了自己的命运。他表达了对他们信任他的感激之情，并鼓励他们在没有他的情况下继续生活。他的母亲向他保证，她会战斗到最后一口气。她不被允许拥抱科林，所以这次简短的会面以一种草率的、
verbal farewell. More than 1,000 people encircled Melbourne jail on the morning of Colin's execution. In his final moments, Colin sat quietly with a reverend and wrote a letter to his family. It read in part, Goodbye my darling mother and brothers. On this, the last day of my life, I want to tell you that I love you more than ever. Do not fear, for I know God will be with me. Try to forgive my enemies, let God deal with them. Do not fret too much for me. The day is coming when my innocence will be proved." When the cell door opened, Colin remained silent. He handed the reverend the Bible he'd possessed during his incarceration, then placed his hand on the reverend's shoulders in a way
口头告别结束。在科林被处决的当天早上，超过1000人包围了墨尔本监狱。在最后的时刻，科林与一位牧师静静地坐着，并给家人写了一封信。信中写道：“再见，我亲爱的母亲和兄弟们。在这一生中的最后一天，我想告诉你们，我比以往任何时候都更爱你们。不要害怕，因为我知道上帝会与我同在。试着原谅我的敌人，让上帝去对付他们。不要为我太担心。我清白的那一天终会到来。”当牢房门打开时，科林保持沉默。他把他在监禁期间拥有的圣经交给了牧师，然后把手放在牧师的肩膀上，
described as more eloquent than words. Colin was then led to the gallows. An experimental four strand rope was used for the occasion, though never again, as it ended up taking upwards of 20 minutes for Colin Ross to die. Colin's prison bible was passed on to his mother. The inside was full of annotations and alterations he'd made to the text to make it relevant to his current circumstances. They depicted a man fighting desperately against a world determined to condemn him, with lines like, "...false witnesses rose up against me.
被描述为比言语更具感染力。随后，科林被带往绞刑架。这次处决使用了一根实验性的四股绳索，但再也没有使用过，因为科林·罗斯最终花了20多分钟才死去。科林的监狱圣经被传给了他的母亲。里面满是他为了使其与当前处境相关而对文本所做的注释和修改。它们描绘了一个拼命反抗一个决心谴责他的世界的男人，写着诸如“……虚假的证人起来攻击我。
They laid to my charge things that I knew not. Time will tell." And, Charge things that I knew not. Time will tell. And The police. Wickedness is in the midst thereof. Deceit and guile depart not from her streets. Melbourne." On one page Colin underlined the words, full of bribes, and wrote next to it. This is our police force which our people think so much of.
他们把我不曾知道的事情加在我身上。时间会证明一切。”以及“把我不曾知道的事情加在我身上。时间会证明一切。”以及“警察。邪恶就在其中。欺诈和诡计不离开她的街道。墨尔本。”在一页上，科林划线标出了“充满贿赂”的字样，并在旁边写道：“这就是我们的人民如此看重的警察部队。”
With the execution of Colin Ross, the Gun Alley murder as it came to be known faded from headlines until eventually people stopped talking about it altogether. Edie Ross maintained her promise to fight for her son's name. She wrote a letter to the people of Australia that urged, "...I view with horror the awful crime for which my son was wrongly executed. I quite understand the indignation and wrath that must sway the judgment of the public at the committal of the shocking deed. But as his mother, I protest with all my soul that my boy should be made the innocent victim of that indignation and wrath. I have gone from place to place, from one to another, pleading for my boy's life, pleading
随着科林·罗斯的处决，后来被称为“枪巷谋杀案”（Gun Alley murder）的案件从头条新闻中消失了，直到最后人们完全停止谈论它。伊迪·罗斯坚持她为儿子的名誉而战的承诺。她写了一封信给澳大利亚人民，敦促道：“……我怀着恐惧的心情看待我儿子被错误处决的那场可怕的罪行。我完全理解公众在犯下这起令人震惊的罪行时所产生的愤怒和愤慨。但作为他的母亲，我用我的灵魂抗议，我的孩子不应该成为这种愤怒和愤慨的无辜受害者。我从一个地方走到另一个地方，从一个人走到另一个人，为我儿子的生命恳求，恳求
for justice and mercy, only to be turned away without hope. As my dear son Colin has suffered all that the law can do to him, I now make a mother's appeal to the public of Australia to help me clear my son's name from the terrible stigma that has been placed upon it. Melbourne, however, was prepared to move on. And it did. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. tent.
正义和怜悯，却被拒之门外，毫无希望。由于我亲爱的儿子科林已经承受了法律对他所能做的一切，我现在向澳大利亚公众发出母亲的呼吁，帮助我洗清我儿子名誉上被强加的可怕污点。”然而，墨尔本准备继续前行。事实也确实如此。Casefile节目很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。
Seventy-one years later, in 1993, a retrospective exhibition on Australian artist Charles Blackman was held at the National Gallery of Victoria. Titled Schoolgirls and Angels, it featured a series of paintings and drawings Blackman produced in the 1950s depicting bleak deserted cityscapes reminiscent of Melbourne in the 1920s. A girl wearing a school uniform and a straw hat wandered among the streets as if lost, her eyes wired in fear. 37-year-old Kevin Morgan was a trainee librarian at the National Gallery.
七十一年后的1993年，澳大利亚艺术家查尔斯·布莱克曼（Charles Blackman）的回顾展在维多利亚州国家美术馆举行。展览名为《女学生与天使》（Schoolgirls and Angels），展出了一系列布莱克曼在20世纪50年代创作的绘画和素描，描绘了让人想起20世纪20年代墨尔本的荒凉城市景观。一个穿着校服、戴着草帽的女孩在街上徘徊，仿佛迷了路，她的眼睛里充满了恐惧。37岁的凯文·摩根（Kevin Morgan）是国家美术馆的一名实习图书管理员。
Every time he walked to his workspace, he passed black men's art. Kevin didn't know what inspired the menacing images, but they intrigued him. He found himself asking, who was this mysterious child? He later explained, quote, There was something about her, haunting and haunted, that seemed to beg the heart. This child had a sense of death around her." Seeking an explanation, Kevin read a catalogue about Charles Blackman that contained quotes from an interview he'd given many years earlier. Blackman discussed his inspiration for the artwork, saying,
每次他走到工作区时，都会经过布莱克曼的艺术作品。凯文不知道是什么激发了这些威胁性的图像，但它们引起了他的兴趣。他发现自己问：“这个神秘的孩子是谁？”他后来解释说：“引用：关于她，有一种萦绕心头且被萦绕的感觉，似乎在乞求心灵。这个孩子周围有一种死亡的气息。”为了寻求解释，凯文阅读了一本关于查尔斯·布莱克曼的目录，其中包含了他在多年前接受采访时的引述。布莱克曼讨论了他创作艺术品的灵感，说道：
"...a schoolgirl was once murdered in a lane near the old Eastern Market, and it left a direct and languished effect on me." Kevin Morgan had never heard of Alma Tursky, but Blackman's confronting art had drove him to learn more about her case. By that point, the families of the victim and the convicted and all the witnesses and investigators involved in the original case had passed away. Key locations like Gun Alley and the Eastern Arcade no longer existed. Still, Kevin dug up as much information as he could, examining newspaper archives and the writings of defense attorney Thomas Brennan. The more Kevin studied the case, the more he came to realize it featured two innocent victims.
“……一个女学生曾经在旧东市场（Eastern Market）附近的一条巷子里被谋杀，这对我产生了直接而持久的影响。”凯文·摩根从未听说过阿尔玛·特斯基，但布莱克曼令人震撼的艺术作品促使他去了解更多关于她案件的信息。到那时，受害者和被定罪者的家人，以及原案中涉及的所有证人和调查人员都已经去世。像枪巷和东拱廊这样的关键地点已不复存在。尽管如此，凯文还是挖掘了他能找到的所有信息，查阅了报纸档案和辩护律师托马斯·布伦南的著作。凯文研究这个案件越深，就越意识到它涉及两个无辜的受害者。
The obvious one was Amitarsky. The other was Colin Ross. Although Colin had died 34 years before Kevin was born, Kevin could feel Colin's presence in everything he read. It felt as though he was crying out for his name to be cleared. Kevin left his job to devote the next seven years of his life to conducting a deep dive into the Tershki case. He reached out to the living relatives of those involved and obtained Colin's old prison Bible which had been stored in a shed. Upon taking in all the messages Colin had scrawled in it, Kevin was deeply affected. He accessed the original court documents absorbing the mess of contradictions and anomalies in the prosecution witness testimony. He read about the witnesses
显而易见的一个是阿尔玛·特斯基。另一个是科林·罗斯。虽然科林在凯文出生前34年就去世了，但凯文在他阅读的一切内容中都能感受到科林的存在。感觉就像他在呼喊着要洗清自己的名字。凯文辞去了工作，将他余生七年的时间投入到对特斯基案的深入研究中。他联系了相关人员的在世亲属，并获得了科林那本一直存放在棚子里的旧监狱圣经。在读到科林在上面潦草写下的所有信息后，凯文深受触动。他查阅了原始法庭文件，吸收了控方证人证词中混乱的矛盾和异常之处。他读到了那些
who had gone ignored but whose recollections might have rescued Colin from the gallows. But the biggest revelation was yet to come. As Kevin examined the archives of the Office of Public Prosecution's library, he made a discovery. Upon looking inside an old, forgotten box, he came across an envelope marked with the words, On His Majesty's Service. Inside were several white cards with a small amount of hair stuck to them. One card was labelled as Alma Turski's hair. The other held the hairs lifted from Colin Ross' brown blanket. In 1922, these hairs played a major role in securing Colin's conviction. Even after so many years, they were as vibrant a red hue as ever. Kevin had been told that all the physical evidence
被忽视的证人，但他们的回忆本可以把科林从绞刑架上救下来。但最大的启示还在后面。当凯文检查公共检察官办公室图书馆的档案时，他有了一个发现。在查看一个被遗忘的旧盒子时，他发现了一个信封，上面标着“为国王陛下服务”（On His Majesty's Service）的字样。里面有几张白色的卡片，上面粘着少量头发。一张卡片被标记为阿尔玛·特斯基的头发。另一张卡片上装着从科林·罗斯的棕色毯子上提取的头发。1922年，这些头发在确保科林被定罪方面发挥了重要作用。即使过了这么多年，它们依然呈现出鲜艳的红色。凯文曾被告知，所有与案件相关的实物证据
pertaining to the case had been destroyed, so this was a major find. With the advancement of forensic technology, Kevin sought to have the hair re-examined. A long bureaucratic and legal battle followed. It took three years, but Kevin was finally permitted to carry out the tests. In 1998, the results were in. An analyst from the Victorian Institute of Forensic Medicine concluded that the hairs were easily differentiated at the microscopic level. There were very clear differences in colour, pigmentation and other features.
都已被销毁，所以这是一个重大发现。随着法医技术的进步，凯文寻求对头发进行重新检查。随后是一场漫长的官僚和法律斗争。花了三年时间，凯文终于获准进行测试。1998年，结果出来了。维多利亚州法医研究所的一名分析师得出结论，这些头发在显微镜水平上很容易区分。在颜色、色素沉着和其他特征上存在非常明显的差异。
They had not originated from the same scalp as had been claimed during Colin Ross' murder trial. The samples were retested by the Federal Police Investigation Unit who concluded, the hairs from the brown blanket could not have come from Alma Tursky. In 2005, Kevin Morgan released a book on his findings titled Gun Alley, Murder, Lies and Failure of Justice. That year, assisted by legal experts, he prepared a petition to the Victorian government asking for the verdict in Almitursky's murder to be annulled. Such requests were typically made by the convicted person themselves, but this was the first time in Australian legal history that the request was made posthumously. Kevin had been given permission to go ahead by both Colin and Dauma's living relatives, who all signed the petition. The Attorney-General considered the petition for a year before referring
它们并非像科林·罗斯谋杀案审判期间所声称的那样来自同一个头皮。样本由联邦警察调查组进行了复检，他们得出结论：棕色毯子上的头发不可能是来自阿尔玛·特斯基。2005年，凯文·摩根出版了一本关于他调查结果的书，名为《枪巷：谋杀、谎言与司法失败》（Gun Alley, Murder, Lies and Failure of Justice）。那一年，在法律专家的协助下，他准备了一份请愿书提交给维多利亚州政府，要求撤销阿尔玛·特斯基谋杀案的判决。此类请求通常由被定罪者本人提出，但这在澳大利亚法律史上尚属首次死后提出请求。凯文获得了科林和阿尔玛在世亲属的许可，他们都签署了请愿书。总检察长考虑了这份请愿书一年，然后将
the matter to the Chief Justice of the Supreme Court of Victoria. Fourteen months later, after the court's most senior judges had pored through all the new and old evidence of the case, a report was completed. They concluded that if the 1922 jury were given access to the recent hair test results, Colin Ross would have been found not guilty. The trial was formally ruled a miscarriage of justice. Referring to the case as a travesty, the Attorney General presented a framed letter of pardon for Colin Ross that was handed to members of his and the Tershki families. One of Colin's nieces felt a great sense of relief, saying, "...I had lived with this fear and doubt for most of my life, the more so as I began to
此事提交给维多利亚州最高法院首席法官。十四个月后，在法院最高级别的法官仔细研究了案件的所有新旧证据后，一份报告完成了。他们得出结论，如果1922年的陪审团能够获得最近的头发测试结果，科林·罗斯将被判无罪。审判被正式裁定为司法不公。总检察长称该案为一场闹剧，并向科林·罗斯的家人和特斯基家族的成员递交了一封装裱好的赦免信。科林的一位侄女感到一种巨大的解脱，她说：“……我一生中大部分时间都带着这种恐惧和怀疑，尤其是当我开始
have children, that perhaps I carried the genes of a murderer. That shadow has gone." Alma's relatives felt the pardon wasn't enough. A second cousin of hers said, "'A pardon means I am forgiving you for something you have done. Shouldn't it rather be an exoneration, which means I accept you didn't do this in the first place." Nevertheless, they were grateful for the impact the pardon would have on the country's collective memory of Alma. One of Alma's nieces said, "...the pardon has also helped restore the reputation of Alma because it shows that she didn't enter the wine bar as was said in the trial. She was a good
有孩子时，担心我可能携带了杀人犯的基因。那片阴影已经消失了。”阿尔玛的亲属认为赦免还不够。她的一位表亲说：“‘赦免意味着我原谅你所做的事情。难道不应该是一种平反吗，这意味着我接受你根本没有做过这件事。’”尽管如此，他们还是很感激赦免对国家对阿尔玛的集体记忆所产生的影响。阿尔玛的一位侄女说：“……赦免也有助于恢复阿尔玛的名誉，因为它表明她并没有像审判中所说的那样进入酒吧。她是一个好
girl. Collins' remains were ordered to be removed from the unmarked prison grave they were resting in so he could be given a proper burial. Melbourne jail had long since been decommissioned and the remains of deceased prisoners buried there were moved around and reburied at different sites. Colin's remains were in a coffin shared by three other men and it took years to track down where exactly they had been placed and which remains among them belonged to Colin. In October 2010, Colin's relatives held a funeral service on his behalf on the site where he'd been executed. The relatives of Alma Tursky attended in a show of solidarity. One of Colin's relatives stated, This morning we leave behind us the cold stones of the Melbourne jail.
女孩。”科林的遗骸被下令从他安息的无名监狱墓地中移出，以便他能得到妥善安葬。墨尔本监狱早已被废弃，埋葬在那里的已故囚犯的遗骸被转移并重新埋葬在不同的地点。科林的遗骸装在一个与其他三名男子共用的棺材里，花了几年时间才追踪到它们被放置的确切位置，以及其中哪些遗骸属于科林。2010年10月，科林的亲属在他被处决的地点为他举行了葬礼。阿尔玛·特斯基的亲属出席了葬礼，以示声援。科林的一位亲属表示：“今天早上，我们把墨尔本监狱冰冷的石头留在了身后。
Colin is at last set free. He is with his family once again. at last set free. He is with his family once again. Colin's remains were cremated and interred beside those of his mother in rural Victoria. Kevin Morgan, whose actions led to Colin Ross's vindication, told the Age newspaper, "... a big stain on the legal system has finally been expunged and a shadow on two Australian families has also been lifted. That justice has finally been done for the Ross and Tersky families after 86 years is a tremendous outcome. Reflecting on the entire experience for his book, Kevin said, 17 years earlier as I walked through the picture gallery pondering the identity of Charles Blackman's schoolgirl, I could not have guessed what ordinary people could do, let alone achieve, in the face of a perceived injustice.
科林终于获得了自由。他再次与家人团聚了。终于获得了自由。他再次与家人团聚了。”科林的遗骸被火化，并安葬在维多利亚州农村他母亲的遗骸旁边。凯文·摩根，其行动促成了科林·罗斯的平反，告诉《时代报》（The Age）：“……法律体系上的一个大污点终于被抹去了，两个澳大利亚家庭身上的阴影也已消除。86年后，罗斯家族和特斯基家族终于伸张了正义，这是一个巨大的成果。”在为他的书反思整个经历时，凯文说：“17年前，当我走过画廊，思考查尔斯·布莱克曼画中女学生的身份时，我无法猜到普通人在面对感知到的不公正时能做什么，更不用说能取得什么成就了。”
With Colin Ross pardoned, the question remained, who killed Alma Tursky? Based on the known facts of the case, Kevin Morgan was surprised Colin Ross was ever considered a suspect. He had no history of sexual-based offending and in Kevin's words he was, "...an impulsive bungling criminal acting without forethought as exemplified by him proposing a gunpoint and the planned robbery that went awry. He could be stupid to put it frankly. In contrast, Kevin concluded Alma's killer was... Someone possessed of a clear mind, capable of thinking ahead and aware of the sorts of
随着科林·罗斯被赦免，问题依然存在：谁杀害了阿尔玛·特斯基？基于案件的已知事实，凯文·摩根对科林·罗斯曾被视为嫌疑人感到惊讶。他没有性犯罪史，用凯文的话说，他是一个“……冲动、笨拙的罪犯，行事没有预谋，正如他提议持枪抢劫以及计划失败的抢劫案所证明的那样。坦率地说，他可能很愚蠢。”相比之下，凯文得出结论，阿尔玛的杀手是……一个头脑清醒、能够预先思考并意识到那种
clues that might disclose his identity. This person was not stupid or careless, may indeed have been educated and appears to have known about techniques of crime detection as they were then applied and the state of forensic medicine in 1922. Other known child killers were tenuously linked to Elmer, but none were considered genuine suspects. While researching his book, Kevin Morgan collated all the information provided by Elmer's younger sister Viola, who was 10 years old in 1921. In doing so, Kevin discovered a chilling secret. After Alma's murder, Viola was plagued by nightmares of being pursued by a male figure through dark places. Sometimes she'd have visions of the man poking his head through her bedroom window. During one nightmare,
可能暴露其身份的线索的人。这个人并不愚蠢或粗心，实际上可能受过教育，并且似乎了解当时应用的犯罪侦查技术以及1922年法医学的状况。其他已知的儿童杀手与阿尔玛有微弱的联系，但没有一个人被认为是真正的嫌疑人。在研究他的书时，凯文·摩根整理了阿尔玛的妹妹维奥拉（Viola）提供的所有信息，她在1921年时只有10岁。在整理过程中，凯文发现了一个令人不寒而栗的秘密。阿尔玛被谋杀后，维奥拉一直被噩梦困扰，梦见自己在黑暗的地方被一个男性身影追赶。有时她会产生幻觉，看到那个男人把头伸进她的卧室窗户。在一次噩梦中，
he entered Viola's room and told her, I came home at one o'clock. Viola believed the man in her nightmares was George Murphy, the husband of one of her older cousins. She sensed George was a pedophile and that he'd wanted to sexually assault her from a young age. It all started when she was around six or seven years old and he rubbed her legs in an inappropriate manner. From then onwards, Viola felt George was trying to groom her. She took to hiding in a wardrobe whenever he visited and asked other family members to keep close to her whenever he was around. On one occasion, he chased her out onto the street and continued to pursue her until she reached safety. When Viola was 16, George asked her to
他进入了维奥拉的房间，告诉她：“我一点钟回家的。”维奥拉相信她噩梦中的男人是乔治·墨菲（George Murphy），她的一位表亲的丈夫。她感觉到乔治是一个恋童癖，并且从她很小的时候起就想对她进行性侵犯。这一切始于她大约六七岁的时候，他以不恰当的方式摩擦她的腿。从那时起，维奥拉觉得乔治一直在试图诱导她。每当他来访时，她就躲进衣柜，并要求其他家庭成员在他周围时紧紧跟着她。有一次，他把她追到街上，并一直追赶她，直到她到达安全地带。当维奥拉16岁时，乔治要求她
marry him. She refused. Viola didn't tell anyone about George's actions at the time as she felt no one would believe her. Her silence was fuelled by the era's conservative culture, as the topic of sex, even non-consensual sex, was never openly discussed. In an interview in 1997, Viola revealed that she wasn't questioned by anybody, including the police, about her sister's murder. Therefore, she never implicated George Murphy in the crime, saying, "...I was kept right out of it. Right out of it altogether." Kevin Morgan discovered that in December 1921, George Murphy was working as a draftsman for the Office of the Register General and Register of Titles. His office was on Queen Street in Melbourne's CBD,
嫁给他。她拒绝了。维奥拉当时没有告诉任何人关于乔治的行为，因为她觉得没有人会相信她。她的沉默是由那个时代的保守文化所推动的，因为性的话题，即使是非自愿的性，也从未被公开讨论过。在1997年的一次采访中，维奥拉透露，没有人，包括警察，询问过她关于她姐姐谋杀案的情况。因此，她从未将乔治·墨菲牵连进这起罪行，她说：“……我被完全排除在外了。完全被排除在外了。”凯文·摩根发现，1921年12月，乔治·墨菲在总登记官和产权登记处担任绘图员。他的办公室位于墨尔本中央商务区的皇后街（Queen Street），
which intersected all the main thoroughfares relevant to the Tershki case, including Burke, Little Collins and Collins Streets. Kevin theorised that after unsuccessfully grooming Viola, George Murphy set his sights on Alma. Of the two sisters, Alma was the more trusting and obedient, a befitting target for a child predator. If Alma had endured any form of sexual abuse, it was reasonable to assume she wouldn't have spoken out about it. The fact that it involved a family member would have made it even more unmentionable. Maybe her uncle-in-law had scared her silent. A month before her murder, Alma told her friends that a spiritualist had warned that she'd die soon.
它与特斯基案相关的所有主要干道相交，包括伯克街（Burke）、小柯林斯街和柯林斯街。凯文推测，在诱导维奥拉失败后，乔治·墨菲将目光投向了阿尔玛。在两个姐妹中，阿尔玛更信任人且更顺从，是儿童掠夺者的合适目标。如果阿尔玛遭受过任何形式的性虐待，可以合理地假设她不会说出来。涉及家庭成员的事实会使它变得更加难以启齿。也许她的姨夫曾吓得她不敢出声。在她被谋杀前一个月，阿尔玛告诉她的朋友，一位灵媒曾警告说她很快就会死去。
Although this story was proven false, Kevin Morgan wondered whether Elmer was exposing a very real fear she had within a fictitious narrative. George Murphy could have threatened to kill Elmer if she exposed his crimes. When George learnt Elmer was leaving Melbourne to live with her father in regional Victoria, he might have feared losing control of her. Outside of his reach, she could be compelled to expose him. As Kevin theorised, George might have felt like he had to silence her once and for all. By the time Kevin Morgan began looking into George Murphy as a suspect in the Tershki case, the records of his former employer were no longer available. Therefore,
虽然这个故事被证明是假的，但凯文·摩根想知道阿尔玛是否是在一个虚构的叙事中暴露了她内心一个非常真实的恐惧。乔治·墨菲可能威胁过阿尔玛，如果她揭露他的罪行就杀了她。当乔治得知阿尔玛要离开墨尔本去维多利亚州农村与她父亲住在一起时，他可能担心失去对她的控制。在他够不着的地方，她可能会被迫揭露他。正如凯文所推测的那样，乔治可能觉得他必须一劳永逸地让她闭嘴。当凯文·摩根开始调查乔治·墨菲作为特斯基案的嫌疑人时，他前雇主的记录已不再可用。因此，
George's whereabouts that day couldn't be proven. When Alma had arrived at the butcher shop on the day of her disappearance, she wasn't in a state of distress. Therefore, Kevin Morgan believed that her ordeal began shortly after she left the shop. Witnesses had reported seeing a man following Alma along Little Collins Street before confronting her outside the Eastern Arcade. Alma wasn't inclined to speak to strangers, so it was possible that she knew the man. Alma had been instructed to leave the parcel of meat at her aunt's flat, knowing that the flat itself would be empty. In a move that was completely out of character for a girl who wrote a school essay titled, Duty First, Alma instead slowly and nervously wandered around to the neighbouring streets, avoiding her intended
乔治那天在哪里无法证明。当阿尔玛在失踪当天到达肉店时，她并没有处于痛苦状态。因此，凯文·摩根认为她的遭遇始于她离开商店后不久。证人报告说看到一名男子沿着小柯林斯街跟随阿尔玛，然后在东拱廊外与她对峙。阿尔玛不喜欢与陌生人交谈，所以她有可能认识那个男人。阿尔玛被指示把那包肉留在她姨妈的公寓里，知道公寓本身会是空的。对于一个写过题为《职责第一》（Duty First）的学校作文的女孩来说，这是一个完全不符合她性格的举动，阿尔玛反而缓慢而紧张地在邻近的街道上徘徊，避开了她预定的
destination. According to Kevin Morgan, quote, the meeting altered Alma's course. She diverged from her route to her aunt's flat ten minutes away because it was no longer a sanctuary. Kevin considered whether Alma had told the man where she was headed and then stalled for time out of fear that he would go there and wait for her. Perhaps she was seeking safety by remaining in a public, populated area. She wandered into the eastern arcade only to realise it wasn't a suitable space for lone children so she headed back outside. Shortly after this, the screams of a distressed young girl were heard echoing up Little Collins Street.
目的地。根据凯文·摩根的说法，引用：“这次会面改变了阿尔玛的路线。她偏离了前往十分钟路程外她姨妈公寓的路线，因为它不再是一个避难所。”凯文考虑了阿尔玛是否告诉了那个男人她要去哪里，然后因为害怕他会去那里等她而拖延时间。也许她通过留在公共、人口稠密的地区来寻求安全。她走进东拱廊，却意识到它不适合独自一人的孩子，所以她又回到了外面。此后不久，一个小女孩痛苦的尖叫声在小柯林斯街回荡。
When speaking to the press in January 1922, investigators leading the Tursky case assured the public. No piece of information was disregarded and every supposed clue was subjected to the closest scrutiny. At that time, the case's lead detective, Fred Pigott, was considered a real-life Sherlock Holmes. A hard-nosed detective with an eye for detail, Pigott was a celebrity due to his work on many high-profile homicide cases. He was widely regarded as one of the best detectives of his era. His work on the Tershki case not only earned him accolades and respect, but credited him
1922年1月在接受媒体采访时，领导特斯基案的调查人员向公众保证：“没有一条信息被忽视，每一条所谓的线索都受到了最密切的审查。”当时，该案的首席侦探弗雷德·皮戈特（Fred Pigott）被认为是现实生活中的夏洛克·福尔摩斯。皮戈特是一位注重细节、强硬的侦探，由于他在许多高调凶杀案中的工作而成为名人。他被广泛认为是那个时代最好的侦探之一。他在特斯基案中的工作不仅为他赢得了赞誉和尊重，还使他被认为
as helping bring forensic science into Australian courtrooms. Detective Pigott had passed away by the time Colin Ross was pardoned. During his illustrious career, he was involved in a case involving a husband accused of fatally shooting his wife. In a groundbreaking move, Pigott carried out what was then the first example of blood spatter interpretation in a Victorian criminal case. He determined that the killing was in fact a suicide, and his work saved the accused from being executed. What exactly went wrong for Pigott in the Tersky case will never be fully understood.
有助于将法医学引入澳大利亚法庭。在科林·罗斯被赦免时，皮戈特侦探已经去世。在他辉煌的职业生涯中，他参与了一起涉及一名丈夫被指控枪杀妻子的案件。在一项开创性的举措中，皮戈特执行了当时维多利亚州刑事案件中第一个血迹喷溅解释的例子。他确定这起杀人案实际上是一起自杀，他的工作挽救了被告免于被处决。皮戈特在特斯基案中究竟哪里出了问题，将永远无法完全理解。
never be fully understood. He was the type of detective to put in the work to ensure justice was correctly served, but had failed spectacularly in that instance. It's believed that Pigott put too much faith in the analysis of the hair evidence, even though it wasn't reliable. Still, this didn't answer why so many significant pieces of evidence that exonerated Colin Ross went willfully ignored. In 1961, Detective Pigott gave an interview that touched on the Tershki case, during which he stated, "...the public were clamouring for police action and the politicians, of course, were harassing us. We survived the uproar long enough to plump for the theory that Ross ravished and strangled Alma in the saloon. But we were well aware that our evidence was only circumstantial. He also said,
将永远无法完全理解。他属于那种会投入工作以确保正义得到正确伸张的侦探，但在那个例子中却惨败了。人们认为，皮戈特对头发证据的分析投入了太多的信任，尽管它并不可靠。然而，这并没有回答为什么这么多证明科林·罗斯清白的重要证据被故意忽视。1961年，皮戈特侦探接受了一次采访，谈到了特斯基案，期间他表示：“……公众在吵着要警察采取行动，而政治家们当然在骚扰我们。我们熬过了骚乱，足以支持罗斯在沙龙里强奸并勒死阿尔玛的理论。但我们很清楚，我们的证据只是间接的。”他还说，
While I suspected Ross, we desired to build up the chain of evidence that was being forged against him. In his book on the case, Kevin Morgan added his own thoughts to this assertion, writing, "...thus, when a piece of evidence could not be forged into a link, it seems it was simply discarded." it was simply discarded. Throughout his time as Colin's attorney, Thomas Brennan had received many letters. Some warned him against helping Colin, while others expressed their support of the condemned man. There were even multiple alleged confessions from someone claiming to be Alma Turski's real killer. Brennan easily recognised the confessions as hoaxes. Some had been penned by Collins' supporters in the hopes they could somehow prevent his execution. But on Sunday, April 23, 1922, the eve before
“虽然我怀疑罗斯，但我们渴望建立正在针对他伪造的证据链。”在关于该案的书中，凯文·摩根对这一断言发表了自己的看法，写道：“……因此，当一条证据无法被伪造成一个环节时，它似乎就被简单地丢弃了。”它就被简单地丢弃了。在担任科林律师的整个期间，托马斯·布伦南收到了许多信件。一些信件警告他不要帮助科林，而另一些则表达了对这名被判刑者的支持。甚至还有多份来自声称是阿尔玛·特斯基真正杀手的人的所谓供词。布伦南很容易认出这些供词是恶作剧。有些是科林的支持者写的，希望他们能以某种方式阻止他的处决。但在1922年4月23日星期日，即
Colin Ross was set to be executed, an anonymous letter arrived at Brennan's office that he felt was genuine. The author left behind no identifying information save for a postmark indicating the letter had been sent from a country town in Victoria. As reproduced in Brennan's book on the case titled The Gun Alley Tragedy, the latter read... To Colin Ross at Melbourne Jail You have been condemned for a crime which you never committed, and are to suffer for another's fault. Since your conviction you have, no doubt, wondered what manner of man the real murderer is, and who could not only encompass the girl's death but allow you to suffer in his stead. My dear Ross, if it is any satisfaction
科林·罗斯被处决的前夕，一封匿名信寄到了布伦南的办公室，他觉得这封信是真的。作者没有留下任何身份信息，除了一个邮戳，表明这封信是从维多利亚州的一个乡村小镇寄出的。正如布伦南关于该案的著作《枪巷悲剧》（The Gun Alley Tragedy）中所转载的那样，信中写道……致墨尔本监狱的科林·罗斯：你因一项你从未犯下的罪行而被判刑，并将为他人的过错受苦。自你被定罪以来，你无疑想过真正的凶手是什么样的人，谁不仅能造成这个女孩的死亡，还能让你代替他受苦。我亲爱的罗斯，如果这有什么满足感的话，
for you to know it, believe me that you will die but once, but he will continue to die for the rest of his life." Honoured and fawned upon by those who know him, the smile upon his lips but hides the canker eating into his soul. Day and night his life is a hell without the hope of reprieve. Gladly would he take your place on Monday next if he had himself alone to consider. if he had himself alone to consider. His reason, then briefly stated, is this. A devoted and loving mother is ill. A shock would be fatal. Himself he will sacrifice when his mother passes away. He will do it by his own hand. He will board the ferry across the sticks with a lie on his lips, with the only hope that religion is a myth and death annihilation. It is too painful for him to go into the details of the crime. It is simply a Jekyll and Hyde existence. By a freak of nature, he was not made as other men.
让你知道，相信我，你只会死一次，但他将在余生中继续死去。受到那些认识他的人的尊敬和奉承，他唇边的微笑掩盖了蚕食他灵魂的溃疡。日日夜夜，他的生活都是没有赦免希望的地狱。如果他只有自己要考虑，他会很高兴在下周一代替你。如果他只有自己要考虑。他的理由，简而言之，是这样的。一位忠诚而慈爱的母亲病了。任何打击都将是致命的。当他的母亲去世时，他会牺牲自己。他会亲手做这件事。他会带着谎言踏上渡过冥河的渡船，唯一的希望是宗教是一个神话，死亡是湮灭。对他来说，深入了解犯罪细节太痛苦了。这简直就是杰基尔和海德（Jekyll and Hyde）的存在。由于大自然的怪癖，他不像其他人那样被制造。
This girl was not the first. With a procurus, all things are possible. In this case, there was no intention of murder. The victim unexpectedly collapsed. May it be some satisfaction to yourself, your devoted mother, and the members of your family to know that at least one of the legions of the damned, who is the cause of your death, is suffering the pangs of hell. He may not ask your forgiveness or sympathy, but he asks for your understanding. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这个女孩不是第一个。有了诱导者，一切皆有可能。在这种情况下，没有谋杀的意图。受害者意外倒下。愿这对你自己、你忠诚的母亲和你的家人来说是一种满足，知道至少有一个导致你死亡的被诅咒的军团成员正在遭受地狱的折磨。他可能不会请求你的原谅或同情，但他请求你的理解。你目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。